على كل المزيد معنا من عمان عمار عمار
المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والمناصره في
اليونيسف لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا اهلا بك استاذ عمار اسمح لي ان
ابدا بما تناقلته الارقام الرسميه من
نقابه الاطباء في السودان تتحدث عن
447 قتيلا في المجمل منذ بدء الاشتباكات
اضافه الى
2255 مصاب حتى الان هل نعلم عدد الاطفال
من بينهم كم هو
شكرا على الاستضافه للاسف الشديد عدد
الضحايا كتير كبير خاصه بين المدنيين وعدد
الاطفال الاسبوع الماضي تقريبا بعد القتال
بكم يوم كان عن تسع اطفال مؤكدين وخمسه
وخمسين طفل جريح لكن هناك صعوبه في في
التحقق من الارقام والاصابات بين الاطفال
بسبب القتال الدائر لكن نحن نعلم ان للاسف
ان الرقم بين الاطفال اكبر من هيك بكثير
وخاصه مع استمرار القتال حيكون في مزيد
بين الضحايا من الضحايا بين الاطفال طب
خبرنا سيد عمار عن عملكم على الارض كيف هو
بالسودان وتقييمكم للوضع الان
يعني الوضع الانساني اذا تقيمنا للوضع
الانساني كارثي للاسف خاصه على الاطفال مع
يعني اكثر من اسبوعين على القتال يضع
الاطفال في وضع كتير صعب من الناحيه
النفسيه وايضا من الناحيه ايضا بحاجه الى
الى الماكل المشطب الرعايه الحمايه الطفل
راينا المدارس ما زالت مغلقه منذ اكثر من
اسبوعين وهيدا طبعا بضع الاطفال في وضعدهم
الانتهاكات جسيمه مثل التجنيد القصبي بين
الجماعات المسلحه
الانتهاكات الجسديه الانتهاكات النفسيه
التي المدارس يعني تقوم في في مثل هذه
الاوقات الحرجه بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
راينا انه في 50 الف يعني عندنا خمسين الف
طفل بعاني من سوء التغذيه الحاد الوقيه
منقطعت عنهم العلاج في مراكز او الرعايه
المنقذه للحياه في المراكز التغذيه
التابعه التي تدعمها اليونسك في خاصه في
مناطق الاشتباكات وهذول حياتهم في قطر
داهم اذا اذا ما استمرت الاشتباكات
هل لكم تحرك على الارض سيد عمار نعم
تحركنا على الارض نحن قمنا بتقديم مساعدات
طبيه عاجله الى العديد من المستشفيات في
الخرطوم كذلك الى عدد الى المستشفيات في
شمال دارفور بالاضافه الى توفير المياه
ايضا لبعض المستشفيات في شمال دارفور
تقديم المساعدات في بعض المناطق التي نجح
اليها
العائلات والاطفال لكن تبقى هذه المساعدات
قليله مقارنه بالاحتياجات الانسانيه
الهائله الموجوده على الارض
لم تساعد على التحرك لانه يجب ان يتم
تقديرها بشكل كامل ويجب ان تكون مكرونه
ايضا بضمانات امنيه للمنظمات الانسانيه
العامله على ارض الميدان فهذول الشرطين
الصين لحتى تقدر منظمات انسانيه اخرى ان
تقوم بشكل فعال وشامل وكامل للاستجابه
للاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله على ارض على
ارض الميدان وخاصه في المناطق التي تشهد
اشتباكاتهم
عندها طبعا
من اكثر من 70 عاما في البلد عندها كان
برامج موجوده لديها الامكانيات حتى تقوم
باستجابه سريعه وشامله عندنا الفرق التي
تعمل ايضا في اماكن مختلفه في السودان
منها
ما تتحققت هذه الشروط لحتى يكون في
استجابه قصوى فهنا يجب ان تكون التركيز في
في الان وفي الايام القادمه انه كيفيه
تثبيت الهدنه الانسانيه لحتى نقدر نساعد
الاطفال المتضررين بعض المنظمات اوقفت
عملها واجلت موظفيها اليونيسف بعيده كل
البعد عن مثل هذه الخطوه
الموظفين غير الاصليين ايضا من مناطق
الاشتباكات لتقليل لحده المخاطر التي يمكن
ان تقع عليهم لكن ما زال لدينا فرق موجوده
مثلا في بورسودان تقوم بالعمل متابعه ايضا
العمليات الانسانيه برفع الجهوديه
بالاضافه الى ذلك لدينا ايضا برامج ما
زالت مستمره في مناطق اخرى من السودان من
ضمنها برامج التغذيه للاطفال الذين يعانون
من سوء التغذيه الحاد والبخيم
وايضا مثل هذه البرامج لكن التركيز الاول
في هذه الاوقات الحرجه يجب ان يكون
للاستجابه للاحتياجات الانسانيه الطارئه
فيما يتعلق بوضع الاطفال الحرج في المناطق
التي تشهد اشتباكات والتركيز على الامهات
ايضا اليس كذلك سيد عمار بطبيعه الحال
خاصه الامهات الذين
هم عندهم اطفال المرضعات
النساء الحوامل لانه هدول طبعا بيكون
وضعهم خطر يجب ان تقدم لهم الرعايه الصحيه
خاصه خاصه في هذه الاوقات في انقطاع مثلا
حكينا عن موضوع المستشفيات انه العديد من
المستشفيات تدمرت او تضررت او اصبحت خارج
الخدمه تمام فهذا بالمقام الاول ثانيا
العديد من النساء الحوامل والمرضعات
والاطفال الصغار ما زالواقين في مناطق
الاشتباكات فطبع في هكذا وضع بزيت الخطر
كثير كبير على حياته خاصه بوجود شخص في
المواد الغذائيه او عدم الامكانيه ايضا
للناس الموجودين في المناطق الاشتباكات ان
يحتوي على المواد الغذائيه وايضا هناك شخص
في الاموال وارتفاع الاسعار الغذائيه التي
كلها هذه العوامل بيكون عائق او بشكل خطر
اضافي على سوق التغذيه بالنسبه للامهات
للامهات وايضا بالنسبه للاطفال في هذه
الاوقات مخزون اليونيسف في السودان هل هو
كافن بمعنى انه بحال تم الاعلان عن العوده
لاطلاق المشاريع التي كانت قائمه اليونيسف
قادره على تفعيلها مباشره
نحن من اشدتنا انه يجب حمايه المنظمات
الدوليه من ضمنها اليونيسف وما خزنها
وايضا المواد التي تعود اليها لحتى تكون
استجابتها كتير سريعه لكن نحن برجع باكد
لك انه نحن استجابتنا حتكون سريعه وشيله
متى الظروف للقيام بذلك مع انه في الوقت
الحالي عم تقدم المساعدات لكن ليس وفقا
للاحتياجات الانسانيه الهائله لانه يجب ان
يكون هناك ضمانات امنيه شامله وكامله لحتى
نقدر نوصل لجميع المناطق المتضرره هلا
تحدثت عن نهب
مخازن ان كانت تابعه لليونيسف ولغيرها من
المنظمات ولكن هل لديكم جرد لحجم الخسائر
بالنسبه لليونيسف او لا
برد فعل سريع ما تتوفرت الظروف لكن
مناشدتنا في هذه الظروف الصعبه طبعا
الحمايه طبعا بالمقام الاول السكان
المدنيين والاطفال من اتبعات القتال حمايه
ايضا
الخدمات الاساسيه التي يعتمد عليها
الاطفال للحياه مثل مثل
الصحه للشرب المستشفيات والمراكز العدازيه
التي تقدم الحياه
الخدمات المنقذة للحياه للاطفال لدينا
يعانون من سوره التغذيه وايضا السماح
للاطفال وعائلاتهم الذين يرغبون في الرحيل
الى اماكن اكثر امنا بالقيام بذلك لكن
بشكل اساسي ايضا وموازي يجب حمايه ايضا
المواد المنقذه للحياه التي موجوده عند
المنظمات الدوليه من ضمنها اليونيسف لحتى
يعني تكون اذا توفرت الظروف نقوم برد فعل
سريع لمساعدتهم اذا استمر ما هو الوضع
عليه حاليا بيضع الاطفال في خطر متزايد
وايضا قدره المنظمات الدوليه على
الاستجابه بكون اقل في الفترات القادمه
المخ بالنسبه لصحه الاطفال في غياب
التلقيح او عمليات التلقيح في كثير من
المناطق اكثر ما يخيفكم بهذا الاطار وهل
من مخاوف من اوئه معينه نعم يعني كان في
الاوبئه الموجوده على سبيل المثال
الكوليرا الميزه كانت موجوده ما قبل
النزاع وكان هناك 11 مليون شخص بحاجه الى
خدمات الوصول الى اعدادات المياه الصالحه
للشرب الى خدمات الصرف الصحي وبالتالي مع
القتال
الدائره الان ما زالت هذه الاحتياجات
موجوده ولكن تضاعفت ومن ضمنها ايضا الوصول
الى المياه الصالحه للشربه للاشخاص
الموجودين في مناطق القتال او الاشخاص في
المناطق الاخرى الذين اصلا لم تتوافق
لديهم المياه الصالحه للشرب سيضطر الى شرب
مياه غير صالحه وهذا بعرضهم ايضا الى
مشاكل صحيه وايضا الى تفاقم مشكله الامراض
المنقوله بالمياه مثل البوليرا والامراض
الاخرى فممكن يكون امام ايضا امراض وبائيه
بتضع الاطفال في في المقام الاول بشكل خطر
فهذا ايضا جانب اخر يجب الالتفات اليه
ممكن يكون على شكل عمل خطر على على
الاطفال لا شك بانكم تتواصلون مع الجهات
المتصارعه لتامين موظفيكم وامين
حركاتكم وتنقلكم هل من تجاوب
طبعا يعني بالنسبه لالنا
مثل ما حكينا اللي كان في النقل لبعض
الموظفين الى اماكن اخرى
لحتى نخفف
مخاطر عليهم كمان ايضا هناك عدد من
الموظفين ايضا
تم نقرهم الى خارج البلاد لكن هناك موظفين
الان نعمل من مناطق اذا بدك امنه لحتى
نقدر نقوم في البرمجه ومتابعه عملياتها
الانسانيه لكن نحن طلبنا الى الجميع
الاطراف المتحاربه انه الوضع الانساني
للاطفال كان كثير صعب اكثر من سبعه ثمانيه
فاصله خمسه مليون طفل قبل الازمه كانوا
بحاجه
مليون طفل خارج المدارس وهناك 3 مليون طفل
التغذيه فكانت الاحتياجات الانسانيه
القتال الموجود الان ما زالت اكثر صار في
خطر دائم على حياتهم فنطلب من جميع
الاطراف انه يكون في هدنه انسانيه لحتى
نقدر بالفعل الاطفال يعني
الشركاء الاخرين ونقوم بتقديم الخدمات
المن حياتهم وايضا السماح لهم ايضا في في
ارادوا ذلك ان يقوموا بالخروج الى مناطق
اخرى اكثر امنا لكن هو السلام يعني الحل
الوحيد للاطفال يعني ما في
اعتبارات انسانيه ما قبل النزاع تبعات
انسانيه هائله الان مع النجاح وبالتالي
اذا ننظر الى المستقبل وضع الاطفال في
السودان يعني في قطر الدائم من عمان عمار
عمار المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والمناصره
في اليونيسف لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا شكرا جزيلا لك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات